(audience clapping)
It's time for Drew's News,
your daily "toot toot"
(Ross laughs)
on the good news horn.
And with me at the desk is my favorite bugle boy,
Rossy, Ross Mathews.
(laughs) Toot toot!
(audience claps and cheers)
Hi.
Hi everybody.
You do toot your tooter!
Toot toots.
Okay, first up,
while we orchestrate our massive makeover today,
Newsweek reports one woman bravely recruited
all of TikTok to revamp her look.
Okay, she is brave.
That is brave.
Yes.
Her name is Alezandra,
and she posted this before look, and then asked Gen Z
to give her some constructive criticism,
and they sure did,
she got-
They sure did.
But they always do!
Uh huh.
And for better or worse,
she got tons of comments and some said,
"Ditch that side part", and some said to
"Lighten up the eye makeup for a fresher look".
Well, Alezandra took it all to heart,
and posted this transformation.
Wow-wa!
Whoa!
I think she looks phenomenal, right?
But I would never do this in a million years.
Ross Matthews is tapping out.
(audience laughs)
If I ask you how I look,
"Do you like how I look?", what I'm really saying is,
"Can you confirm that I think that I look good?".
(Drew and audience laugh)
You know, so the fact that she went on social media
said, "Hey, strangers, give me your two cents."
Not gonna happen!
(audience laughs)
You are stronger and braver than I am.
All right, for those who like the middle part,
raise your flower.
Green, gimme green.
Oh, whoa, so much green.
Okay.
You guys, I hate to disagree,
but I kind of love the side part.
I do too.
What I really love is the fresh makeup.
Yes.
I think that's the real game changer.
All right, next we've got some style news.
Some old footwear is making a big time comeback,
and it's (laughs) not just for milkmaids anymore.
(Drew laughs)
PopSugar reports, you know clogs?
Well, they're clogging on back.
They say people are going to be clogging
hither and thither this fall.
(audience laughs and exclaims)
(laughs) I hear the audience, they don't know.
Clogs are not for everyone, Drew.
I have to ask you, are you a clogger?
I do not have the leg for a clog.
A clog does not look like a clog on me,
it looks like a hoof.
(Ryan and audience laugh)
I'm not kidding.
Listen, I know my body, I know tailoring,
Yeah.
and clogs are not flattering on me.
Well, you know what I got into this summer,
and I can't even believe I'm gonna admit this,
but Ross Mathews got into Crocs this summer.
What?
(audience laughs and exclaims)
Yeah, I know, I was near the pool,
I went to the mall one day, and I was like,
that's kind of cute, they put these little things on them,
so I thought, no-one will ever know, just buy a pair.
Jibbitz?
Jibbitz!
(audience laughs)
And then I was rocking out with my Crocs out
all summer long,
(audience laughs)
and now look, clogs are a whole trend.
So did I start it, am I a hero?
I don't know, you tell me.
(audience laughs)
Green flowers for in with the clog,
red for out with the clog.
Let's see what you guys think.
A lot of mixed, surprisingly more green
than I would've thought.
Well, go clogs.
I love that we're really debating the issues
the nation needs to talk about.
(audience laughs)
Thank you for this.
Listen, we talk about it all on the news.
(laughs) Yes, of course.
And next, we're always ready to turn this desk into a lab.
Today, we're trying the latest skincare trend.
Glamour reports that the frozen cucumber trick
is going viral, and dermatologists say
they might have something to this.
What? (laughs)
Cukes are loaded
with vitamin K, can reduce puffiness,
and help with acne and dark circles.
So we have frozen cucumbers here.
These are legit so cold, that we wrapped a towel around 'em,
and I just rub this all over my face?
That's the, that's the, um, suggestion.
(audience laughs)
Okay. (laughs)
But guess what?
(laughs) What?
We have someone in our audience
who's gonna do this with us.
Hi, who's this?
Hi.
Oh, it's Cat,
ladies and gentlemen!
Hey.
Hi, Cat.
Give her a warm welcome.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Cat, are we gonna really do this on television, Cat?
I'm ready.
Cat, I would like you to lead this beauty session.
Okay, I'm going to start at the eye area,
'cause that feels more appropriate.
Okay. (laughs)
Oh my God, that's so cold, whoa!
It smells nice.
It does feel like a, like a real product
that you'd buy at a store, though.
You know?
Yeah, a grocery store, Cat.
(everyone laughs)
No, like one of those roller things.
Cat, I'd like to know,
Yeah.
what your thoughts are.
Yay or nay to the cucumber?
I feel refreshed.
I say yay.
Yeah, I don't know that I'm sold.
I think,
(audience laughs)
I think I'm good, I smell like a salad, Drew.
I think I'm good.
Well, I just liked getting to do that with you, Cat.
(Cat laughs)
Thank you so much.
Thank you, that was fun.
(audience claps)
And Rossy, I loved it.
And natural.
And, before we go, I wanted to share
a powerful image by photographer, Ellie Sharp.
It's a really good reminder that social media
is a veneer, it is a slice,
it's just not the whole apple.
And we are doing a beauty show today,
but one of the things that I really, really,
really can't press upon enough,
I just think that beauty is a spiritual
and an emotional journey, as well as the way it looks.
And social media can really play a lot of tricks on us.
This is who we are, this is what we've got to work with,
and we need to feel good about it,
and be kind to ourselves, as well, in the process.
Mm-hm, well said, Drew.
(audience claps and cheers)
You know what else is beautiful, Ross?
What?
You.
Well girl, it's the cucumber, you gotta try it.
(Ross and audience laugh)
So is Cat, and it ain't the cucumber.
It's you.
(upbeat music)